in this video I want to talk about the
areia cycle in more detail so in the
last video we talked about how we
created carb and 1l phosphate which sort
of started off this cycle so that costed
us two ATP's to actually make that
carbonyl phosphate a carbamoyl phosphate
in the mitochondrial matrix of a liver
cell now in order for this carbon mono
phosphate to move on to the urea cycle
it needs to join with this molecule here
this molecule here is called ornithine
now ornithine is an amino acid this has
an alpha carboxyl group here and alpha
amino group here and an alpha hydrogen
and then an R group so it's an amino
acid but you'll notice that it wasn't
one that we talked about as being part
of the 20 amino acids and that's because
it's not a protojet amino acid it
doesn't it's not coded for by the a
codon table so it's not incorporated
into proteins so that's why we didn't
talk about it before but it is an amino
acid nonetheless and it actually looks
exactly like lysine except it's one ch2
group shorter so ornithine is initially
in the cytosol the liver cell it needs
to get into the liver mitochondrial
matrix in order to join with carbamoyl
phosphate so it needs this little orange
dot i've drawn here it's a protein that
allows us to transfer transport into the
mitochondrial matrix so that is actually
an ornithine transporter now once that
transporter gets ornithine into the
mitochondrial matrix it joins of carbon
level phosphate and then a phosphate
group hops off when and this molecule
here is created this molecule is called
citrulline now citrulline basically just
has the carbonyl portion of carbamoyl
phosphate tacked onto ornithine at this
amino group here which is what we have
here now citrulline is in the liver
mitochondrial matrix it needs to leave
and get into the cytosol in order to do
that in order to get out here it needs
this transporter here that transporter
is of course a citrulline transporter
now once I sit
on the cytosol we're going to use an ATP
turn it into a pyrophosphate so that the
equivalent of two ATP's used there and
that's in this step here and we're going
to create this molecule here which is
basically which is called a Citra lleol
EMP so it looks partly like citrulline
and has an A MP on it pretty much what
it is it's got this mostly the
citrulline here except at this carbon up
here we have an A MP attached to it now
that is that's it's really a MP what
we're going to add to it is this
molecule here this molecule is you
should recognize it as a sport eight
okay
so we had this is an amino acid it has
the carboxyl group amino group H and the
R group so I've labeled the I've drawn
the amino group here in blue so once
this part 8 comes in to incorporate
itself into this situation PMP actually
hops off and what we get is this a sport
a attaches right here at that carbon and
then we get this molecule here this
molecule it's now called our G no
succinate why is it called our G no
succinate well let's think about this
for a second RJ no should probably come
from arginine an amino acid that we
learned before and succinate we've seen
that intermediate in the TCA cycle so
this portion here you can tell looks a
lot like succinate right all it needs is
this needs to be a ch2 so this can hop
off as as a succinate and this portion
here looks a lot like arginine so it's
just an arginine with a sex in it that's
two it's as simple as that our G no
succinate what's going to happen to that
is that the succinate is going to come
off as a Boomer rate now that's
important because this fumarate you
should know is part of which pathway
that we talked about before this could
go to the TCA cycle or the krebs cycle
and why is that important why would that
be useful well because we can get energy
from the
we can get energy from that fumarate so
all the steps that after fumarate so
fumarate could actually yield us one
nadh from the male a dehydrogenase step
which is the equivalent of 2.5 ATP why
on earth is that useful or important
because this 2.5 ATP will basically
reduce the overall cost of the urea
cycle because there's energy investments
involved in the urea cycle which we
talked about just a moment ago so that's
important there now once that fumarate
hops off that we should be left with
this arginine here which is actually
what I've drawn here so this is arginine
arginine okay so now arginine now has
this red portion here from the carbamoyl
phosphate and this blue portion here
from the aspartate which you've drawn
over here and then that portion right
there is actually going to be the part
that hops off as urea so we add water
and get this portion to hop off as urea
and then that arginine regenerates this
ornithine which can is now ready for
another round of the cycle so of course
this product here this urea where does
that thing go well it is excreted right
as a waste product
it is excreted either in the urine or
sweat so that's pretty much it as a sort
of general recap and overview where in
the body is all of this happening which
Oregon it's happening in the liver but
we're in the cell specifically does the
urea cycle occur well some steps occur
in the mitochondrial matrix and some the
rest of it occurs in the cytosol
furthermore carbamoyl phosphate
synthetase one or cps one is the first
committed step which is we've talked
about before
first committed step and it's actually
highly regulated it regulates the flux
of nitrogen through the cycle oops
so it's highly regulated excuse me and
specifically
of nitrogen is regulated at this step
all right the step in which the carb I
am what the carbamoyl phosphate is
actually made hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching one last thing I
am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email at move University at gmail.com
and see the description below for more
details thanks for watching